cuál sería el proceso con el que se
reabriría la frontera
bueno hay que tener algo presente y como
bien mencionado así esta situación bien
se sostiene hace más de siete años ha
fluctuado la frontera no ha estado del
todo cerrada lo que se cierra hacia el
paso de los vehículos se sabe que en las
noches pasan vehículos y en su ambiente
a veces se ha prestado mucho para redes
de corrupción en la zona el anuncio no
es un anuncio que nos sorprende es algo
que ya ha gustado pero había anticipado
y aquí lo que hay de fondo es bien lo
que mencionabas también es las
implicaciones políticas que precisamente
esto tiene en las relaciones
binacionales y también en la misma
comprensión de venezuela en el
continente ya usando estado mencionando
de alguna manera que significa para
ambas naciones esta reapertura de la
frontera también en términos sociales y
económicos
bueno esto es algo que definitivamente
venía reclamando norte de santander
particularmente y toda la zona de
frontera
especialmente el restablecimiento del
comercio que es uno de los temas
principales y una de las exigencias
sobre todo el sector empresarial y es
algo que no queda claro en los
renunciamientos por eso digamos ese
tweet que sale y algunos
pronunciamientos
anteriores no dejar todo claro a qué se
refiere con ese restablecimiento y si
esto conducirá rápidamente al
restablecimiento de las relaciones
consulares y lamar bueno y justamente un
eventual restablecimiento de relaciones
qué implicaciones tiene para colombia en
la región son muchos los países que
condenan el gobierno de nicolás maduro
bueno por un lado hablar de relaciones
consulares es algo que se necesita los
venezolanos y las venezolanas que se
encuentran en colombia necesitan algún
tipo de protección por parte del estado
venezolano esto es algo que habrá que
mirarse también con lupa porque eso
significa que ahora el estado en es
humano no puedes aparte de la
responsabilidad que se ha zafado en los
últimos cinco años ya en cuanto a
relaciones políticas y relaciones
diplomáticas nicolás maduro gana un
nuevo aliado probablemente uno de los
aliados más importantes en la región y
más allá de eso la oposición venezolana
pierde su más importante aliado a nivel
regional bueno y otra pregunta que
podemos hacer en este tema es cómo ver a
este movimiento de la oposición tanto en
colombia como en venezuela
con esto claramente fija una nueva ruta
una nueva era en relaciones no solamente
binacionales sino la forma como se
configura la región esto también le da
un respiro a nicolás maduro y parte del
cerco diplomático que se ha tratado de
mantener que si bien no los efectos que
se deseaban si ha dado como ha traído
consigo ciertas consecuencias de
visibilizar la situación y esto podría
hacer mucho más dramático el proceso y
además dejar la oposición aún más sola
en lo que se esperaría los próximos
diálogos en las mesas en mexico